We're on problem 70.
And they still want us to do
some sequences and series.
What is the n'th term in
arithmetic series below.
Which means that it just
increases by a constant amount
every term.
So let's think about
it a little bit.
The first term is 3.
And then we increment
it by 4 each time.
Let me write all of this.
3, then we go to 7, then we go
to 11, and then we go to 15,
then we go to 19.
So we go to 3 and we're
adding 4 every time.
So you get the sense that each
term in the sequence is going
to be 4 times the n'th term.
But that doesn't
quite work out.
Because I've had 4 times-- if
this is the first term, 4
times the first term is 1.
And 3 is less than 1.
And then 4 times 2 is 8.
And 7 is less than 8.
And 4 times 3 is 12.
But this is 1 less than 12.
So it seems like all these are
1 less than a multiple of 4.
So the n'th term is going
to be 4n minus 1.
And that should work out.
The third term is 4 times
3, 12, minus 1 is 11.
And that's the third term.
So it's 4n minus 1,
which is choice D.
Next problem.
Problem 71.
Let me copy and paste it.
Acctually, I'll copy and
paste all of them.
All right.
Which expression represents f
of g of x if f of x is equal
to x squared minus 1 and g of
x is equal to x plus 3?
So a lot of times, these
seem daunting.
But when you get used to it,
these become kind of fun
problems. So f of g of x means,
in f of x , everywhere
you see an x you have to
replace it with g of x.
So f of g of x is equal to
g of x squared minus 1.
Now, all I did is if I said f of
dog, wherever I see an x, I
would replace it.
So f of dog would be dog
squared minus 1.
Whenever I see an x I just
replace it with whatever I
input in right there.
So they want to know f of g of
x , I stick a g of x there.
So it's going to be g of
x squared minus 1.
But what's g of x?
Well g of x is x plus 3.
So this is going to be equal to
x plus 3 squared minus 1.
Which is equal to x squared
plus 6x plus 9 minus 1.
plus 6x plus 8.
Which is choice B.
Next question.
Given that f of x is equal to 3x
squared minus 4 and g of x
is equal to 2x minus 6,
what is g of f of 2?
Well here, since they gave us
an actual number, so they
didn't leave it abstract, we
could figure out what f of 2
is and then pop it into g.
So what's f of 2?
Yeah, you should be able to
see that color. f of 2.
Wherever you see an x, you
replace it with 2.
So that equals 3 times
2 squared minus 4.
Which is equal to-- 3 times
2 squared, 2 squared is
4 times 3 is 12.
Minus 4 is equal to 8.
So f of 2 is equal to 8.
So g of f of 2 is
equal to g of 8.
And what's g of 8?
g of 8, everywhere you see
an x, just pop in an 8.
Is equal to 2 times 8 minus 6.
Is equal to 16 minus 6.
So this is equal to 10.
Choice D.
Problem 73.
If f of x is equal to x squared
plus 2x plus 1 and g
of x is equal to 3 times x plus
1 squared, which is the
equivalent form of f
of x plus g of x?
So essentially they just want us
to add these two functions.
So if we say f of x plus g of
x-- let me do that. f of x--
and I'll do it in another
color-- plus g of x.
Well now we just add them.
What's f of x? f of x is x
squared-- I'll do it down
here-- x squared
plus 2x plus 1.
That's f of x.
Then we're going to add
g of x to that.
Oh, I see why it's a little--
they want us-- g of x you kind
of have to expand this out.
So g of x is 3 times
x plus 1 squared.
Well that's 3 times x squared
plus 2x plus 1.
But then from here we just have
to simplify this all out.
And I'll do that in a
third neutral color.
Brown color.
x squared plus 2x plus 1 plus--
distribute the 3-- 3x
squared plus 6x plus 3.
And now let's see, you have an
x squared and a 3x squared.
You add those together,
you get 4x squared.
And I have a 2x and
I have a 6x.
Add those together,
I get plus 8x.
And then I have a 1
and I have a 3.
So plus 4.
4x squared plus 8x plus 4.
And that's choice C.
Next problem.
Next page.
All right, let me see.
What do they want
us to do here?
A math teacher is randomly
distributing 15 rulers with
centimeter labels and 10 rulers
without centimeter labels.
All right.
What is the probably the first
ruler she hands out will have
centimeter labels and the second
ruler will not have
centimeter labels?
So, OK, let's think about
the first one.
I'll color code it.
So what is the probability that
the first ruler she hands
out will have centimeter
labels?
So there's a total of
25 total rulers.
15 with centimeters
and 10 without.
At least initially, there's
a total of 25 rulers.
And they want to know the
probability that the first
ruler she hands out will
have centimeter labels.
So 15 have centimeters.
So the probability
is 15 over 25.
That's the probability
of the first one
having centimeter labels.
That's that one.
But they want to know, the first
one having centimeter
labels and the second ruler not
having-- and you can't see
that highlight color-- and the
second ruler will not have it.
So this is-- so we're going
to have to multiply the
probability of the first ruler
times the probability that the
second, without labels, and now
this is the key-- given
that the first ruler
had labels.
Now this might all seem really
complicated with the notation
but when you think of it
intuitively, it should
hopefully make some sense.
I've given away-- so the first
ruler there's a 15 out of 25
chance that I've given
a ruler with labels.
Now on the second ruler, since
both of these things have to
happen, I can assume that I've
already given away the first
ruler having labels.
So how many rulers
do I have now?
Well I definitely have
24 rulers left.
And now, how many of these
do not have labels?
Well the first ruler I gave
away had a label.
So I still have 10 rulers that
do not have a label.
If you wanted to ask a similar
question, you could say what
is the probability that the
first two ones that I hand out
have labels?
That would be 15 over
25 times 14 over 24.
Because the labels would've
been decremented
after the first one.
Because we're assuming.
We have to say both of
these things happen.
Now we're saying, OK, we're
going to have one less ruler
but I haven't reduced
the number of
rulers without labels.
But anyway, let's just
simplify this out.
This becomes 15 times 10
divided by 25 times 24.
You can do a lot of canceling
so we don't have multiply--
let's see, divide that
by 3, get 3.
Divide that by 3, get 5.
Divide that by 5, you get 1.
Divide that by 5 you get 2.
3 times 2 is 6.
So this is equal to 6 over 24.
Which is equal to 1/4.
Which is choice A.
Next problem.
Let's see.
Problem 75.
On a certain day the chance of
rain is 80% in San Francisco
and 30% in Sydney.
Fair enough.
Assume that the chance of rain
in the two cities is
independent.
What is the probably that it
will not rain in either city?
So it's going to be the
probability of not rain, not
in San Francisco, times the
probability of not in Sydney.
Because we have to have both of
these things happening and
they're independent.
So the probabilities will
be multiplying.
So what's the probability
of not
having rain in San Francisco?
They gave us the chance
of having rain as 80%.
So the probability of not
having rain is 20%.
Or, I like to stick
to the fractions.
20% is 1/5.
There's a 1/5 probability
of not having rain.
What's the probability of not
having rain in Sydney?
It's 30%.
Actually, I probably should've
stayed in decimal world.
So let's say it's 20% in San
Francisco of not having rain.
The probability of Sydney of
not having rain is 1 minus
30%, or 0.7, which is a 70%
chance of not having rain.
And that is equal to--
2 times 7 is 14.
We have two numbers behind
the decimal point.
So there's a 14% chance
that it will not
rain in either city.
And that is choice B.
Next problem.
Well actually I'm out of time.
See you in the next video.